[Musique]
mais où est ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on
n'est pas très loin de meudon à côté de
paris si vous situez pas me dont c'est
normal parce que me dont s'est collé à
paris et je suis venu ici pour vous
parler de voitures du futur pour vous
parler l'électrique j'étais invité par
renault pour six d'entre apercevoir le
futur de l'automobile made in renault
pour faire simple on va parler énergie
énergies renouvelables on va parler
électrique on va parler hybride et tout
ça je vous le montrer c'est extrêmement
passionnant parce que vous le savez on
est dans une vraie transition au niveau
de l'automobile transition au niveau des
énergies fossiles vers des énergies
renouvelables dehors une voiture
beaucoup plus propre il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire qu'ils sont passionnantes
je vous emmène à l'intérieur vous allez
voir le tout est assez dingue en fait
parce que c'est un vieux hangar et vous
avez une seynod signé renaud qui est
juste top je vous emmène vous allez voir
excusez moi mais il faut le dire
regardez le lieu c'est assez incroyable
vous allez vraiment ce vieux hangar qui
est dans son jus avec les vitres cassées
moi j'adore c'est vraiment magnifique
on en prend plein les yeux et c'est
vraiment incroyable
pour parler de voiture électrique et du
futur via renault je me suis dans un
petit loup juste à côté du grand hall
dans lequel on est où je passe un
événement comme ça je vous emmène dans
un côté où on est bien on reste là le
mot nerfs on est très à l'abri donc ça
c'est très cool alors justement il ya
trois points qui sont essentielles pour
pouvoir parler de mobilité de demain une
voiture de demain et comment est-ce que
renault conçoit l'automobile de demain
on va parler de smart cities qui est la
ville du futur
on va parler de smart mobility qui est
le véhicule du futur et on va parler de
smart rose qui sont également les routes
du futur alors je sais pas si tout ça
vous parle énormément on va essayer de
décrypter sa au travers de différentes
interviews de différentes personnes que
j'ai pu rencontrer directement
aujourd'hui lors de cette très très
belle journée va être très très belle
journée en deux le soleil en plus en
pleine tête c'est vraiment bien et comme
ça on y est et on peut bronze en même
temps ça c'est vraiment très très cool
mais la question de l'avenir de
l'automobile ne passe pas que par
l'automobile s'en prenant mais c'est
vrai ça passe également par la question
de la smart cities la smart city c'est
quoi et bien c'est une vie et plus
connecté
c'est en quelque sorte la ville du futur
bonjour carlos moreno et a beau jour bon
je dois donc vous êtes professeur de
l'université experts des villes
territoires demain également spécialiste
du contrôle intelligents des systèmes
complexes
absolument carlos moreno j'aimerais
qu'on parle avec vous de la ville du
futur
à quoi va ressembler la ville telle
qu'on la connaît par rapport à
l'automobile à l'horizon 2025-2030 la
place sociale de la voiture a changé et
il ya dix vingt ans la voiture statut
social avant tout c'était une manière de
montrer ou cherchell où la possession
professionnels et avant toute chose et
donc on était capable une heure non de
kilomètres pour but d'être voulons d'une
grosse voiture qui vont très conne était
quelque part réellement important
aujourd'hui donc face à un problème d
climatiques en particulier aux
mouvements de jeunesse
qui se mobilisent les raccorder paris 10
à 5 ans il ya une prise de conscience
que la place de la voiture et doit
changer dans les villes et donc à
l'horizon dé cinq dix ans et on insiste
déjà un mouvement à mesure irréversible
dans lesquelles est la voiture c'est
plutôt un aspect de la mobilité et la
mobilité
c'est une manière de et être en relation
avec nos activités urbaines
on parle aujourd'hui de ville du futur
on parle de smart city quelle est votre
vision à vous au delà de la vision liées
à l'automobile d'une ville plus proche
de l'humain
mon paradigme il est basé sur ce qu'on
appelle la ville durable avec les
concepts triplé 0 et produits ferment a
media luz zéro carbone zéro exclusion
zéro pauvreté
donc nous on dit il faut créer de la
valeur écologique économique et sociale
dans chacune des villes c'est à dire
donc très peu d'émissions sur deux mieux
répartir la richesse produite par les
activités professionnelles et lutter
contre l'exclusion qui ronge aujourd'hui
une société avec tous ses dérivés
le racisme intolérance comment créer de
la valeur de l'eau du comité social dans
des villes d'abord il faut donc donner
un cadre nouveau à la ville toujours
d'huile est caractérisée par et du
productivisme
donc on produit massivement pour
consommer massivement on a sacrifié la
qualité demi on a sacrifié les tentes il
est même le transport en commencé trois
quarts d'heure en moyenne pour aller à
venir donc quasiment une heure et demie
x sans que ça fait une journée perdue
dans les transports donc nous
effectivement dans mes travaux à la
sorbonne il ya un tarif de proposer ces
concepts de la ville dé proximité et la
ville des quarts d'heure où les
territoires des demi heure c'est à dire
des retrouver une ville avec des multi
centralité et dans lesquelles 1 chaque
moule des centralités j'ai une profusion
de service pour que je puisse dans
qualité pas loin d'un travail au moins
par un accès technologique et pouvoir
faire mes courses et avoir accès à la
santé à l'éducation à la culture et aux
loisirs
on parle beaucoup de smart city avec une
vision peu technologique derrière est-ce
que vous pensez que la technologie à
elle seule va permettre à ces smart
cities de voir le jour est ce une
finalité est ce une nécessité
ou alors est-ce qu on peut complètement
son passé j'ai eu l'honneur et le
plaisir d'avoir développé un franc
soleil de première plateforme
technologique dans les merci au monde
donc on déjà ça remonte à 2006 et
j'avais appelé ça la vie numérique
durable est donc cette technologie est
utilisée en
une start up qui a eu du succès par la
suite et m'a montré quand on a commencé
à faire tous ces gros déploiement ses
limites dont la technologie
c'est en montant un outil et part au
calme en est aussi une science donc je
parle de tout ce qui est lié à carter
aux algorithmes il doit pas nous faire
perdre le nord
on ne peut jamais réduire les problèmes
de trafic des circulations dans des
villes qui est un problème complexe
parce que au laser feux rouges qui
parlent entre eux impossible ou parce
qu'on pense que la voiture autonome va
résoudre le prenez la mobilité c'est
pareil c'est pas possible c'est parce
que on doit reconfigurer la vie urbaine
parce qu'on doit éviter que les gens se
déplacent tous à la même heure
en même temps à traverser toute la ville
ce qu'on appelle les heures de pointe
pourquoi les heures de pointe parce
qu'on répond à une organisation sociale
du travail du siècle dernier du 20e
siècle
il faut aller vers une nouvelle
configuration travail ce que j'appelle
les corps power king les corps power
kepco soleilles cowork s'est
décentralisé ses grandeurs à 3000 4000
5000 10000 personnes qui concentre les
heures de pointe qui concentrent
beaucoup de voitures une tisane autres
solistes pour aller à cette fois là il
faut laisser éclater maintenant sur des
corps poverty des petites unités
décentralisées dans les villes dans
lesquelles ils ont bien trop de travail
et il s'agira pas trop loin de chez eux
un quart d'heure mais ce ne sera pas
tout à fait chez eux et avec des pelles
et des outils technologiques
c'est comme si c'était dans leur lieu de
travail ils seront là de trois heures
par semaine et ils n'iront travaille
physiquement qui quand c'est absolument
nécessaire
c'est vraiment très intéressant je
remercie beaucoup carlos moreno c'est un
plaisir non ces routes
[Musique]
on parle ensuite de smart mobility c'est
de comprendre la voiture du futur
bonjour yasmina cf bonjour j'ai mes
petites filles je sais tout sur vous
vous êtes directrice de programme
énergie et infrastructure de recharge
cherdo est-ce que j'ai tout juste moi je
voudrais qu'on parle de smart changé
ouais
de quelle manière est ce que renault
travail et met en place des innovations
pour réussir à mieux optimiser les
batteries des véhicules électriques
oui alors ce parc harding ça veut dire
recharger intelligemment et ça veut dire
surtout recharger au bon moment d'accord
donc en fait aujourd'hui nos
utilisateurs un conducteur du véhicule
va arriver chez lui le soir à la maison
et ben il a branché sa voiture et il va
brancher et la voiture la batterie va
commencer à apprendre de l'électricité
c'est la question qu'on se pose c'est
est-ce que c'est le bon moment de
l'échangé exactement à 19 heures quand
on rentre à la maison
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas attendre un
peu et chargé au moment où l'électricité
finalement est le moins cher
ou alors chargé au moment où il ya de
plus de renouvelable sur le réseau ou
bien changer ne pas changer surtout
quand il ya des tensions sur le réseau
électrique des fois en hiver en france
en hiver il ya des tensions sur les prix
donc ça c'est la recharge intelligent
qu'on met en place pour nos clients est
en fait la complexité que vous arrive
voyez un peu de complexité la danse et
que finalement on doit contrôler la
voiture
le client il ne ressent pas tiens ils
arrivent ils branchent sa voiture est
par contre on a des mécanismes et on
travaille avec des start up
technologiques qui nous est finalement à
faire le lien entre nous la voiture
électrique et le marché de l'énergie et
contrôler la voiture et la particularité
c'est qu'on utilise la connectivité de
nos voitures d'accord donc ce qui est
génial parce qu'on n'a pas ou on n'est
pas obligé d'imposer à nos clients
d'avoir des bornes
intelligent d'avoir des bonnes connectés
qui coûte cher toujours aujourd'hui donc
puisque la voiture est connecté à un
contrôle directement la voiture au bon
moment où on recharge on gagne de
l'argent en génération on oui on gagne
de l'argent sur les marchés électriques
et une partie de ses deux revenus mao
qui enfile ça veut donc dire que le soir
je rentre chez moi je branche ma voiture
elle va pas forcément se recharge à cet
instant là elle le fera plus tard quand
arrive sera plus intéressant exactement
de l'intérieur où la situation du réseau
sera le mien parce qu'ils sont dépassés
séduit dans le tarif des voix s'est pas
vu sur le tarif mais cbi par le réseau
parce que c'est le réseau électrique et
qu'il ya des tensions et par contre ce
qui est important de ce que voulait dire
c'est que je branche ma voiture la
voiture charge quand il faut mais le
lendemain j'ai ma voiture essentielle au
bon niveau donc je sais c'est une
application qui auquel je dis je vais
partir demain matin à 7 heures moi
yasmine je parle à cette heure donc je
sais que mon autonomie assurée le
lendemain je vous parlais d'une étude or
je sais pas si c'est une étude vous êtes
en train de faire ou en tout cas une
mise en situation sur une île où on va
justement réussir à réutiliser l'énergie
des batteries de véhicules électriques
ne point expliqué ioukos qui sait si il
s'agit d'un projet qu'on a lancé qu'il y
en a
on a bien avancé d'ailleurs dans sur
l'île de porto santo au large des açores
au portugal
et là on va un cran plus loin de ce que
je venais vous de vous expliquer sur la
recharge intelligente parce qu'on parle
de recherche bidirectionnelle seul
espoir ça veut dire que la voiture n'est
pas seulement en charge pas la voiture
tellement bon moment mais en plus on
sait le décharger donc avec ça on peut
apporter encore plus de possibilités de
contrôle pour le réseau électrique qui
en a besoin
en fait paru sur une île comportementaux
et ils doivent ils veulent installer des
renouvelables beaucoup plus de
renouvelable
aujourd'hui un peu de solaire mais 85 %
de leur production est toujours basé sur
les diesels sur le donc pour que 100% de
leur inertie soit renouvelable donc
solaires ou éoliens
il faudrait qu'ils aient ce qu'on
appelle du stockage de la flexibilité
pourquoi parce que
le solaire est intermittent l éolien et
intermittents qu'il n'y a pas de vent il
y aura d'électricité le soir fait nuit
il n'y a pas de d'énergie solaire donc
on a besoin de stocker quand il y en a
dans les voitures vont être utilisés
comme des batteries sur roues chez les
habitants
partout où ils sont en modèles
distribués et l'intelligence qu'on
apporte semences et de pouvoir les
contrôler au bon moment quelle est la
vision de renault justement par rapport
à ça parce qu'effectivement on dit
qu'aujourd'hui du poids du consommateur
une voiture électrique sert à alimenter
et apporter un autre mode de d'énergie
plus propres en cas sur moins
d'émissions de co2 quelle est la vision
de renault aujourd'hui en disant écoutez
nous on va utiliser dans votre lit
différemment dans un écosystème est ce
qu'il ya une vision qu un peu plus
lointaine peut être sûr de la ville plus
propre
d'accord la vision celle de dire non
seulement on bat des carboni mais le
transport la mobilité mais en plus de ça
on utilise et on profite de la batterie
pour apporter d'autres services et pour
justement dans les villes de demain dans
les villes intelligentes
où les écoquartiers passait vraiment à
l'électricité propre
donc ça c'est un peu de la vision kona
en disant que ces bois turquie égard et
90 % de son temps deux choses 1 il faut
que ça soit enfin on croit vraiment à
l'adoption de autopartage vraiment
l'autre partie ce qui est important
d'un côté dans ces quartiers là mais en
plus de ça on divin même l'aîné
l'électricité peut être partagée parce
que les stocker dans cette voiture est
ensuite utilisée pour pouvoir
voilà profiter de l'énergie solaire
l'éolien
le plus écouté je remercie beaucoup
yamina merci et puis ensuite la smart
rôdeur un smartphone ou un sujet qui est
très intéressant et une table ronde qui
a été donné avec trois intervenants
différents le premier intervenant est un
intervenant de renault qui nous parle
d'une techno je voulais d'été dans
quelques instants le deuxième
intervenant est une personne de
l'entreprise colas est la troisième
personne une personne qui vient à des
néo 10 dans le futur en tout cas ça va
être testé très très très prochainement
sur une section de route à paris et bien
vous allez pouvoir recharger vos
voitures directement en roulant sa part
un peu fou mais c'est vrai en fait c'est
la recharge à induction c'est à dire de
la recharge sans contact telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui en tout cas pour les
smartphones vous allez voir votre
véhicule qui roule intégré à votre
bitume vous allez avoir une source
d'énergie qui va être emmené et c'est
justement là où intervient colas qui eux
vont fabriquer le bitume et enée disent
qu'ils vont emmener l'énergie jusque là
ce qui fait que vous allez rouler sur la
route et votre voiture en arrivant dans
cette zone là et bien va reconnaître
qu'elle est restée dessous et va venir
se recharger ça ça plusieurs bénéfices
qui sont vraiment intéressants déjà vous
n'avez pas besoin d'être à l'arrêt pour
recharger votre véhicule
vous pouvez donc recharger tout en
roulant ça c'est un très gros bénéfices
et je pense que jusqu'à présent on
l'avait pas forcément entraperçu en tout
cas moi ce qu'on nous tepa est ce que ça
vraiment vraiment pertinents le deuxième
usage qu'on pourra voir des batteries
beaucoup plus petit dans nos véhicules
pas ce que vous n'allez pas avoir besoin
d'accumuler beaucoup d'énergie puisque
vous allez pouvoir rouler sur des smart
road qui sont équipés de cette
technologie de recharge à induction est
ce que ça veut dire pour autant qu'on
n'ira pas à recharger son véhicule la
nuit à une borne nom serait plutôt une
énergie complémentaire gurs et notamment
un bénéfice pour les personnes qui
roulent énormément on pense au btc on
pense aux taxis on pense aussi aux
livreurs aux différents coursier qui
pourront bénéficier de cette énergie
alors aujourd'hui les véhicules
électriques ne sont pas prêts du tout
pour cette techno il faut imaginer
pouvoir les adapter ce qui sera
probablement le cas lors des phases de
tests qui vont commencer à arriver très
prochainement dans l'est de paris plutôt
dans la zone de bercy mais pour
l'instant on n'en dit pas plus et
renault ne communique pas davantage là
dessus mais il faudra bien évidemment
des véhicules électriques à l'avenir qui
vous permettront complètement d'utiliser
cette technologie en tout cas de masse
ça montre un point qui est vraiment
extrêmement intéressant c'est comment
est ce qu'on arrive à adapter
l'automobile comment on arrive adapter
les villes et que mon arrivée adapté et
la route pour la rendre toujours plus
pratique et surtout beaucoup moins
polluante
dans quels délais peut-on imaginer cette
technologie développée par grand public
on serait plutôt à l'horizon 2028 2030
donc autant dire qu'on a encore
largement le temps et en plus de ça et
ce qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
que ces technologies ovale imaginé en
ville
bien évidemment mais aussi sur des zones
autoroutier alors vous avez pas
forcément voir toute une ville où tout
une autoroute qui va être équipée de
cette technologie mais des portions les
portions des pour venir vous rechargez
et ça c'est plutôt bien
[Musique]
vous le savez toutes les problématiques
qu'on a aujourd'hui avec l'automobile
est bien c'est qu'on est sûr des
énergies fossiles des énergies fossiles
qui sont limitées même si on arrive
toujours aujourd'hui en avant mais
surtout des énergies qui sont
extrêmement polluante directement depuis
votre véhicule bien évidemment l'énergie
électrique a aussi une phase de
pollution notamment lors de la création
en france ont créé de l'énergie grâce au
nucléaire mais à toutes les
problématiques de traitement des déchets
nucléaires pompent à en traiter si
aujourd'hui ce que c'est un sujet qui
est quand même très très basse il ya
aussi des problèmes d'énergie qu'on peut
trouver en dehors de la france notamment
en allemagne et en chine avec des usines
au charbon dont il ya toujours
aujourd'hui un problème de pollution
liés à l'électricité mais ce qui est sûr
et là où est le bénéfice direct c'est
qu'avec une voiture électrique
eh bien on va pas avoir cette pollution
directe en sortie de véhicules donc ça
reste malgré tout un vrai bénéfice
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir au final de
tout ça parce que la question de la
mobilité c'est vachement intéressant est
ce que renault nous propose l'est tout
autant
est-ce que les voitures demain ce seront
des voiture complètement électrique si
on se projette à l'horizon 2050 2100
peut-être peut-être pas de nouvelles
énergies seront peut-être utilisé
comment est-ce qu'on va réussir à
optimiser nos vies comment est-ce qu'on
va réussir à mettre tout ça en place à
articuler ces différentes problématiques
comment est-ce qu'on va réussir à mieux
charger à optimiser nos batteries à
optimiser les systèmes de charge a
optimisé par conséquent nos villes et
nos modes de fonctionnement c'est tout
l'enjeu qui est en tout cas discuter ici
aujourd'hui par renault
et mis en place toutes les solutions qui
sont proposées toutes ces innovations et
on le voit bien évidemment pour te parle
d'automobiles en parle bien évidemment
de voitures telles qu'elles sont on le
sait mais on parle de bien plus de
choses on parle de vous on parle de
votre vie de votre vie au quotidien on
parle des enjeux qui nous touche tous
réellement et au delà de l'automobile
parce qu'on peut se dire je n'ai pas de
voiture ça ne m'intéresse pas mais au
delà de l'automobile ce sont nos modes
de vie et nos modes de consommation
actuels qui sont à la fois en train
d'évoluer et qui seront bouleversées
très prochainement le sujet très
intéressant d parce que vous vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire pour moi
c'est vraiment une révolution qui est en
train de s'opérer que ce soit pour
l'automobile que ce soit pour l'asile du
futur toutes ces questions aussi qui se
rejoignent bien évidemment avec les
questions de la 5g de la voiture que les
tv ça on en reparlera beaucoup plus tard
et croyez moi ce sont des sujets qui
sont passionnants sur ce tout en grâce
je donne rendez vous très bientôt pour
les fans ou yahoo
[Musique]